this is a standout report the US economy
hit a record so maze data marking the
92nd straight month of job growth so
that's a record streak American
employers hiring the most workers in
health care that was by a clear margin
but then that's followed by retail
professional services then construction
and leisure and hospitality round out
the top five categories so unemployment
for african-americans fell to a new low
of 5.9 percent female jobseekers a lo as
well three point four percent the data
points indicate an easier start for
recent graduates to job openings are at
a two decade high anecdotally some
company leaders say it's difficult to
find highly skilled worker positions
some even complained that once they find
talent they have to pay more to keep
valuable employees on board those
comments fit with the increase in wage
growth that we saw in May for about a
decade economists we're wondering how is
the economy growing without wages going
higher and it was this really stubborn
statistic but as of today that is
changing so month on month year-on-year
figures of both show that wage growth is
up 0.1 percent better than forecast it's
pretty tough to find fall with this
report it signals the right balance for
investors too which is why you saw the
stock market react as it did the Dow
closed up by more than 200 points S&P
500 in the Nasdaq each by 1% this report
is solid enough to indicate that the
Federal Reserve will raise interest
rates as forecast at the next meeting
June 12th and 13th economists say the
economy in the u.s. is strong enough to
take the raise